[Music]
what an absolutely
oh what a ledwell today I'm joined by
one of the toughest players in the game
the Tongan born loose board has an
inspiring story moving from Tonga to
Chase's rugby game and he made an
instant impact finishing his school
rugby as the best New Zealand rugby
player at schools with winning the
Golden Boot he also had a brief stint
with Auckland and the blues after school
before moving down to the Tasman Marco
and the Crusaders where he's had a very
successful run of winning titles he's
also been a very key member of the
Tongan International side who will head
to the Rugby World Cup this year and of
course he is at Absolute lad he's one of
the greats he is the Tongan axioni
havily welcome brother thank you thanks
for um having me Jimmy mate good to have
you on I've spoken to you over the last
few end of season dues and you've always
said you're willing to come on so
um great that you can finally get you on
yep I'm looking forward to um you know
tell my story and
been wanting to do this the last couple
years and um
now we um I'm here now yeah I'm proud of
you for even um stepping out and being
willing to come on because I know it's
not comfortable especially for
um Tongans and I I if almost the tongue
guys I ask to come on they're like [__]
no no way I'm coming over here trying to
talk to you but um no proud of you for
even coming here and um
you know being willing to share your
story thank you because yeah you're
again you've got a good one and I know
you're going to inspire a lot of people
from it
so let's start there obviously the last
few few days you just want another Super
Rugby title
um it's probably why our voices are both
both still a bit husky but you've had a
massive run of Titles since you've been
here and what was the what was the
latest one like what's the feeling like
I think that
the last one on side of there
was probably the hardest um
final I've been involved sure
um
in terms of we've like we play the
Chiefs
at their home ground
um we had so many injuries this year I
wasn't even supposed to play
but because we had few injuries um
yeah Rosa gave me the um you know the
opportunity to start is six and um yeah
I can last week was probably the hottest
final I've been involved
um
wow that's crazy and could you say you
weren't given opportunity every time
you've had an opportunity to where the
Crusaders Jersey man you've always
delivered every time yeah
um
yeah every time I bought on the Jersey
I love it
um I wanted to um
give everything because this team meant
a lot um
came down here looking for opportunity
and
the steamer gave me that uh no need to
play but it
provide me the opportunity to go play
for my country too so every time every
time I put on this jersey I'm always
wanted to um you know give back and give
everything for this um this club they
certainly did that and even in the
celebrations how was that for you you're
always one of those guys who right out
the front and the celebrations always
the last one to sleep
[Music]
no I do love um you know I do love a
beer after
after you win something you know
um all the hard work you um
you did before the year and then you
know to come up at the end of the season
with the trophy um yeah I always look
forward to for you know it's the
celebration after the finals yeah the
crazy thing is that's that's all you
really know at Super Rugby level You've
Won it every single year you've been a
part of this team man yeah it's crazy
man
um
2020 and
to furnace my my time here
with a trophy and um yeah it's crazy man
I've never thought of um I play Super
Rugby or play for this team and yeah to
finish my time here with another
trophies yeah unreal and your body's
feeling good you got through the season
injury free yeah one of the few that's
the first time
um
the first time I when I finished the
season with no injuries yeah
hopefully I can you know stay like that
for the rest of the year so yeah because
obviously you've got a big Rugby World
Cup campaign to start on so what's that
look like for you Wendy's windy head
away
um the camp start on the fifth
um it'll be next week so
yeah had to fly out to Tonga um
um on the fourth and get ready for um
you know the walk up we've got a few
games
um
I think we play yeah our first game will
be Australia home
and then we'll play some more Fiji Japan
and then Canada twice before we um go to
World Cup right nice build up so what
are you um what are you expecting from
the the Tongans obviously you've got a
very strong side on paper a lot of
quarterly players have come back or made
themselves available for Tonga now so
pretty good squad on paper what are you
expecting at the World Cup
yeah we've got we've got um we've got a
good team
um
we'll just need to uh we just need to
play together
um
we've got a few games lead into the
World Cup hopefully um you know
all those games will
you know help us you know bring a lot of
confidence lead into the World Cup and
hopefully we
know
beat those uh you know those big names
and yeah yeah well you guys will
definitely be a good chance first time
for a World Cup to you for you as well I
say yeah
um looking forward to it yeah I can't
wait
um
yeah I can't wait to be part of it it'll
be you know it'll be cool yeah go to
woke up and hopefully um play Play a
couple games and that um tournaments uh
hey I think you're going to be a massive
part of the tongan's side and a key part
to how successful they are so
um on the biggest stage too it's going
to be it's going to be awesome for you
yeah
everyone get to see the Tongan accent no
doubt there'll be a few highlights at
least
but I'm Keen to hear more about your
story obviously
um
how the Tongans uh I guess uh brought up
over there and your journey to moving to
New Zealand to pursue your rugby career
it's probably the big thing I'm really
Keen to hear about um from you on this
one so
um give it give us to it give it to us
from the start in terms of growing up in
um Tonga how was it for you when I guess
when you're first born yeah
um
come from a family of four yeah um
my dad mom and my older brother there's
only two of us
um we don't have a sisters um oh yeah
growing up in Tonga was
it wasn't easy
uh we um
we had a good we had a you know um
comfortable or I would say like just a
happy you know normal life back home and
um
all we yeah as a young kid growing up
all we all we wanted to do is
you know play rugby
um
every kid's at home trying to be here
you know
probably rugby somewhere else or because
that's the only thing that we knew as a
young kid's growing up it's rugby that's
the only sport that we play back home
and
um
yeah
yeah oh I'll start with the you know
when I'm
we came up with Disney Channel and um I
can't remember what year was it
2013 one of the Tongan under 14.
we'll play you know play most of the big
big name High School in Auckland and
then our first game was against organ
grammar
um straight after that um I was lucky
enough for
you know get a scholarship to move to
New Zealand the following year sure
um
yeah moving to New Zealand was tough
um knowing that I had to leave my family
mum and dad at home and
so I moved here moving to move into a
fam like family in Auckland stay with
them for a couple years and then
my last year of school
um I was lucky enough to get another
scholarship to the whole store
um I think
my last year at school um with that
scholarship to move into the Hostel at
Cana
help me or make me just to focus on
Rugby because knowing
the reason why I'm here for rugby
um
yeah on my last year I just focus on
playing well and
and I was lucky enough to you know sign
off Auckland
my first two two years out of school
is it your parents who raised you your
birth parents who raised you oh what's
the story there so
have you lose my birth my real last name
okay
um but
I got adopted to
um my real dad's first cousin oh that's
right it's a normal it's a normal back
home that's why I only got one brother
oh okay um but and my real family
um
so that's why I got adopted to the um
my dad's first cousin uh that's why they
have the Teletubbies my last name now
yeah um
I thought yeah I decided to change my
you know my last name to my adopted
family
um
it's a growing up it was tough you know
having to live a family that
I don't have their last name um
you know yeah once I you know met in
rugby I decided to
owner order my fam my adopt their family
you know
if it wasn't for them I reckon
I want to be here like in New Zealand
now yeah when did you realize that you
were you had been adopted or like what
age did you realize what it what had
happened and
did you do you still speak to your uh
original parents yeah yeah
twice probably twice a week okay yeah
um but my adopt the family um
they told me as soon as I started
speaking
um just started to explain I was adopted
and they always take me to my arm I
thought they found my real dads to meet
my siblings yeah so I was going
yeah sometime I'll go to sleep at my
Royal parents sometimes they you know
stay in my um but my top Day family
never
like they never stopped me from you know
going to see loving my my real family
you know
and I find it tough now
um
it's probably most most Islanders out
there um
are the same as meal you know in right
I'm making you know making
money rugby now but
I still have to share you know my income
with my real family and my doctor family
at the moment like you know
and I'm I'm sure that there's people a
lot of people out there are
you know the same um
but here's like
my adopted family they never let uh stop
me from you know loving my real parents
and
the only that's that's why I changed my
last name didn't want to move the
heavily out of my yeah my name I wanted
to just you know move heavily to my
middle name and then add my um I adopted
Family's last name to my name now just a
way to you know all of them for what
they have done for me over the years and
yeah that's
Mom and Dad too uh my mom and dad's now
you know they're happy to see their last
name on TV so that's that's so cool so
obviously it's part of the culture but
what is the reason to adopt the youngest
as a financial thing to give the others
a bit of upbringing or
the
in our culture um
um when you get adopted the reason why
maybe their family don't have a sister
oh okay maybe they don't have a brother
maybe they all the kids are all you know
yeah all boys and they needed a sister
or maybe they're all girls and
they needed a um a brother I'll try
um but because my my adopted um family
they only had one son
and another
um they needed a brother so that's why
they adopted me sure yeah that's cool
and then did you two play rugby
constantly in the backyard or where did
your love from rugby before rugby come
from
well my love from rugby because my old
man my world dad used to play football
okay I used to play football and I think
that's weird
my love for rugby started um
when I found out that my old man used to
play
um as a young kid's young kid growing up
back home that's all we knew is rugby
and the Rugby field in our village was
not far probably 50 meters away from my
house and I go there every day um
after school you know play rugby you
know with all the you know the Neighbors
in the kitchen in our village and
now like all the all the the boy the all
the the boys they used to the way older
than me they used to play right um right
before my Village
now they all have kids and um
wife they don't play rugby anymore but
they
they remember me as a young little you
know young kid running around always
wanted to you know
always wanted to be involved in like the
older voice chopping them yeah
um and I was the yeah I was I was a
naughty boy growing up yeah what sort of
travel did you get into
drinking oh yeah what age uh
we eat like nine ten fire out yeah but I
wasn't like a heavy drinker I was just
like at nine yeah because I always
follow up like follow the older boys oh
yeah and they always like because I was
a little kid like naughty kid yeah
um always wanted to like do what the
order was you know and yeah that's how
like yeah I started drinking when I was
a young kid um what sort of stuff were
you drinking beers or like Spirits yeah
yeah but like I would never finish like
a whole bottle of just like yeah a
little sip yeah
um
smoking like all that kind of stuff
which was a young kid
um
they saw her when I looked back now I'm
man
all the um all the stuff that I did when
like a younger boy like you know
um
yeah well and when you went over to New
Zealand was it the same were you still
no when I came up with the New Zealand I
didn't drink yeah
I thought there was a before I started
in high school oh okay and then when I
started in high school I wasn't like
doing any of that kind of stuff I was
focusing rugby sure what changed what
what made you change there was it just a
mindset switch or how do you how did you
go away from the
add stuff into sort of the rugby path
I think look back now
I think I think there's a reason why I
did it as a young kid now I don't do it
like you know
but I imagine I've I've known people
back home they were like you know no
drinking no smoking they didn't do
anything any of that kind of stuff as a
young kid now are they doing it um as
they get older but I look back now like
I did that out of your system yeah I
have to work through there now there's a
young kid now I'm like you know yeah
I don't do that kind of stuff um I still
drinking and stuff yeah
but
that's fascinating and um Keen to hear
about like your move from Tonga to New
Zealand like how how hard was that for
you did you speak any English or
um how scary was it for you to move from
Tonga to
um New Zealand by yourself
I can talk about
um my high school work back home I went
to a school called um to Paul College
uh at the boarding school everyone had
the board um you know so you
schools the schools start on Sunday so
everyone had to be back um no not Sunday
uh Saturday afternoon
Saturday so you go to school on Saturday
um
and then on a Friday you can go home
but once so you buy your mom and dad
will come and see you Sunday they will
bring the best food on a Sunday all
right and they will come and see you
again on Wednesday
I think
that's cool
um because at that school you go to
sleep on time
you don't eat food and not you know you
don't get full all the time you don't
eat enough food you train hard
you go to the farm every day sure yeah
tough that's
how to explain it to you you know people
here in New Zealand like what's the life
in their school's life
and it's probably the hardest um
yeah the highest hardest thing ever done
like we're getting back in now like all
right
So when you say school you're not
actually in a classroom no you got you
go to school during the day oh yeah but
like how we have our calendar here yeah
it's like everything's time
um
you woke up at 6 6 35 every morning
shower make your bed
you pray every morning every everything
you do at start with a Break
um go to school
lunch
go back to school
um go to the farm
and then come home after when you finish
in the farm training start oh okay and
then
sometimes like
um you missed the dinner
and you end up wanting to end up not
eating anything after you train so hard
in the afternoon
um and then you do that every single day
sure and then on a Friday
um
that's when you like you know look
forward to
go home
um go to like go to town yeah you know
sometimes you know
if you do have a girlfriend
um you would have always yeah
I
didn't have a girlfriend when I was you
know in high school back home
but yeah so you might from Sun Saturday
to the Friday so Fridays they always
look forward to you know yeah go home
and you
because you take all this clothes you
know everything but there's only one
uniform that you save for that day
you say they've won uniform that's all
brand new just to wear it to go to town
you know
um yeah
well no wonder you were Keen to get to a
New Zealand school just to get out of
that obviously if it's the toughest few
years of your life yeah
um moving here to New Zealand was
probably the hardest yeah
not so
it was hard as it was hard in terms of
like English yeah different way yeah
different way I remember my first day um
my first day at Grandma
um
and because
I couldn't like you know I couldn't
speak English at all nothing nothing
um
the only word I I knew back then it was
like mother father oh yeah yes no
but I remember yeah my first day um you
know
um my first day of Grandma like
because I got him you know gonna talk
and stuff um
one of the teach uh the one of the
teachers there she she kind of
understand no
It's Gonna Stand like what I'm going
through and she decided to put me in the
um easel yeah so I spend probably two
years
just study English yeah didn't do any
other like other um Clash of focusing
learning English yeah and I was lucky
enough
[Music]
um
the people that I hang out with oh it's
all baloney boys oh yeah yeah
um
even now they're still my like best mate
um every time I go out to Auckland we
always hang out and stuff yeah but
those guys
man I'm so grateful for them you know
because they never laugh you know they
never um they never make fun of you know
make a make fun of or mock me if you
know if if I don't get the word right or
yeah you know
but they always like
the way they talk to me was real slow
um
sometimes they try to collect uh correct
my English sometime but yeah English is
probably the hot yeah
it made us so you know so hard because
man back home
I started to realize when I came here
man I sort of just focused on like
learning English back
but you know I'm skipped school I never
like because of their school the school
I went back home it was like
my mindset was like you know rugby or
whatever you know want to go overseas
and play rugby and didn't really didn't
really like focus and in school
I was just like rugby rugby rugby and
then until I came over and I was like
man
I wish I was you know focusing you know
and like study English back home yeah
well that's cool that you're um
obviously your supportive Network
um when you move definitely helped you
because I could imagine how easy it is
to be picked on or bullied but also
imagine not many people would be too
Keen to bully you either I could imagine
you being a bit of a scrapper were you
were you a fighter at school now not a
fighter always tough um
I was as I when I was little
um like I said before I was naughty I
was like I always wanted to fight oh
yeah
um why has I got you know got a little
bit older like I was like nah that's not
me
um
but yeah it's cool like
I didn't to be honestly like I didn't
get poorly at all like the only time I
felt like I was getting poorly was
people like to start laughing it like
you know in my English
that's the only time I felt like um I
got bullied like in the school
but yeah no one really like you know
tried to bully me face to face that's
too scary man no I wasn't scared like
you know
I just didn't have time for that yeah in
high school another thing at high school
I guess is everyone always respects the
guys who are good at rugby as well and I
guess that's where you came in as well
you were uh absolute gun at Schoolboy
level and people obviously knew what a
talent you were so they probably wanted
to be your friend yeah
um
yeah I had you know I had a few people
like that in high school um but
the people like
the people that care
and look after me in high school they're
the people that um
we're still you know store you know talk
to each other every time I got up to
Auckland or we're playing Auckland that
was you know
try to catch up with them or ask if they
want to come to the game you know
because they were the one that helped me
you know and um
before I met in rugby um but yeah did
you always know you were going to make
it at rugby did you did you know you
were gonna be good enough
I'll say yeah
um I just
I just believe you know I believe in
myself
um
I work so hard you know I worked so hard
I had my
as a young kid I had a dead dream of you
know moving to New Zealand or you know
somewhere around the world
and I'll you know I had that I always
you know worked so hard and
and when you I know obviously when you
won the Golden Boot award
um being the best school boy
player in New Zealand at the time what
sort of pressure did you feel from that
or was that sort of you realizing that
you were gonna make a career out of it
on my last year at school I signed off
Auckland start of the Year oh really
yeah I started I signed with Auckland
Academy or was it academy uh Sony
Academy of Science for two years I
started I signed it way before the the
season start of my last year oh yeah so
how do you like knew that pathway was
yeah they only knew like you know once I
finished school I'm gonna move into like
you know professional area and stuff you
know I was like yeah but that's why I
like when I said I'm moving to the
hostel
sign of Auckland so my last year I was
just like you know focusing like playing
well and you know try to give back to
the you know the school
um
the pressure that I had from
from that golden book um
now I don't have that anymore but my
first two years out of school like
knowing that the guys that
got that award are all all blacks
and I had I put so much pressure on
myself like man I need to be an all
black
um I had to I had I had the dream to be
in over
like the pressure of like resuming their
award
and yeah it was so much like it was
actually too much yeah too much pressure
for me
knowing that like Addis ABI it was you
know he got their award and a few other
you know big name yeah right yeah
that's interesting eh that you felt all
that pressure because you'd won that
award yeah held your back more than
rather than gave you confidence that you
were good enough yeah it's more more
like from the people outside yeah
they always like talking man you you
call them you call the quote imported
like
I decided and like in my head I was like
man I have to you know I have to you
know I had to make the All Blacks
because
yeah you know those guys you know got
their Awards oh so and then how did you
find your first few
um years or first year in the Auckland
set up going into that environment
tough yeah it was tough because
I can't remember I think
and with Organic um Academy like if you
have work I didn't have a job you know
and I was living off
I was living on I was living off eight I
can't remember I think it was eight
grand
for how long
for the whole year a year a year
hopefully I was living on um yeah eight
grand but again yeah there was my my
um my yeah that's my first contract with
Auckland all right I was living on an
eight grand
um because I got him work um
because my Visa back then I was only
allowed
um
I was only allowed to make
make money through rugby oh yeah so I
wasn't allowed to like do another job do
another job all right but I was like
um a guy you probably know him his name
um Ben Meyer he was the Auckland um
academy uh manager back then oh yeah and
he helped me a lot man I'm so grateful
he you know sometimes he'll find me a
job like cash job
some um sometimes he would just give me
the um
the fuel fuel card oh yeah yeah you
could fill up my card because he knew
that I couldn't you know yeah work and
yeah it was it was tough in the academy
um
and because if you work in the morning
if let's say you work at start at seven
you have to be in like
going to the gym get your training done
before you go to work
and then I was yeah I did that because I
wasn't working I was like just trying
trying yeah
um
yeah and and then did you get any
opportunities to play yeah I did
um because that year we um we
my first year out of school this one day
under 19 tournament oh yeah yeah
so
I was training for that under 19.
um we had we had a good team that year
um
yeah yeah we did yeah because we won it
that year
um but hey there like I was I think
the Auckland miter 10 back then wasn't
going there well like then it went there
many games and they had a few injuries
um before the under 19 tournament
um yeah they yeah they asked me if they
gave him they said if um they're gonna
name me to play so at debut against
um waikato at Eden Park that was the
news before that
scary man yeah it was scary but I
remember uh Jerome kind of said to me
you're playing with your own yeah all
right play with them
he just said to me he won the golden
book too didn't he yeah
yeah I remember because I I remember
before the game I just said to a man do
you ever feel nervous
um before game yeah he said yeah he's
still very tired every time but he just
said to me like
um just go you know once you get out
there and whatever action you do first
action you do make sure you like
you know that's how you set up your game
and I still remember even now like
that's my
that's how I like if I'm starting or
coming off the bench
whatever like you know whatever X you
know whatever the first thing I would do
there is make sure that this this is how
I set up my you know the rest of the
game yeah you can see it it's usually a
hard ax tackle right around someone's
mouth yeah
[Laughter]
uh
oh that's cool that you're playing with
Jerome and yeah that Auckland side man I
I said to him one time
um yeah you do
um
we're on the purse I said to a man
I used to watch you
um back home I was still in primary
and now I'm I'm playing with you yeah
well you started here just start
laughing yeah yeah it's crazy it's crazy
it happens at how fast it happens and
you'll see it now where some kids some
of these guys coming through like your
son Noah he was probably at Prime ring
when you I know
so how did the move to um Tasman come
about why'd you leave Auckland
now
so my like my fish out of school with
daybrew Falkland um
went into play the under 19 I got the uh
um the the player players the tournament
that for the 19 again even more pressure
awesome yeah
um
Dan I went from
Academy contract to a full contract
signing off Auckland for another two
years sure after the under 19 tournament
yeah and then in 2018 I was
um a sign of Blues is a injuries cover
um
I think back then because I wasn't I
didn't have the I wasn't allowed to play
in New Zealand the 20s I wouldn't did
all the the camp oh I've done the
tournament but I wasn't allowed to play
you played New Zealand schools was cool
um
so I got a injuries cover with the blues
and
for them in 2018.
and I was like man I'm actually you know
going good here
um
1.19 you know go into a full contract
now with Auckland Now debut for the
Blues
and I was like yeah I'm gonna you know
have a good idea and
then and after the Super Rugby season I
got um you know the coaches back then
four corners
are we allowed to say the name yeah
Philo and uh Alama um
um they come in
after you know after the Super Rugby
season
right you need to come in we need to
talk to you
in my head I was like oh man they
probably you know you're gonna tell me
what what they want me to do and then
the miter 10 season yeah I know walk
into their room I still remember
I walk into that room them two sitting
there and myself shot the door
and I was like oh yep and then
the first question they asked me
in the room was like do you reckon your
reckon you're ready to be you know
you're good enough to be in the Super
Rugby team
and I said to him I'm like
oh I said to them I was like yep I think
I am I just debut for them and I've been
training with the Blues
and the problem I said no they were
ready sure yeah they said I'm not ready
um
this they when police asked them about
me to do a pretty um preseason with them
they told him not isn't the totally not
to take me
but the blues still end up um gave me
the contract all right
oh man yeah it was probably yeah that
was the hottest
talk like face to face with like coaches
I've like eventually like you know
remember they pretty much told me that I
wasn't good enough
and
they they said to me in in their room
that
I was in I wasn't going to play you
might attend a year
and then he had to explain it to me you
know we got you know
we got Hoskin we got my kiddo we've got
Blake Gibson
and I was like okay that [__] fair
enough like you know I understand like
those guys are Super Rugby they you know
big you know
and they said to me like you can stay
here
and play Under 19
um play development
and then we we'll call you in and I was
like uh
let me think about it you know so I left
the room
rang my agent shot away
told him that Auckland just told me
they're not gonna name me
I'm full contract for two years they're
not gonna name me
and I'm not staying here wasting my time
playing development I want to play Super
Rugby next year but I'm not staying in
the play development
and um a couple days after that uh
manual two um
the first one that came they were
keenness and like yeah I was I said this
to them because I just wanted to play
you know this first one that came yeah I
just wanted to play you might attend
their year and
yeah look the same the same day I said
yes to one or two so they had all my
flight everything ready
later that later that they um Leon call
me oh yeah yeah Leon called me and he
said to me like we're looking for loose
food and we think that you are you're
the person that we're looking
um we want it um you know I was in my
head I had no idea though I don't know
anything about attachment don't know
Nelson
you know yeah call my agent and my agent
said yeah you need to go there because
they're they're on the top four uh
they're on the top four
throw it away drive to Eden Park
went upstairs
to the um CEO room you've ever heard the
story before yeah
yeah I told Shane and goodie about it oh
yeah went into the uh see your roommates
at home
um I'm gonna go to Tasman
and he said nah you're not going there
and I was like why
so did he did he said no to Tasman but I
said yesterday oh I try yeah and I
called my agent again I was like why is
he like not letting me go to Tasmanian
and my agents didn't yeah because Tasman
our top four yeah and you know they're
on the top four and
he probably don't want you to go help
them
um then yeah it took me I think it took
me like it took me a week
Oakland didn't want to release me all
right they didn't actually didn't want
to release me and my agent was like not
jump on the go on the plane go to Nelson
I'll call this on Rugby
um so yeah when the Tasman yeah where
did Nelson yeah
um and then yeah my agent you know
finished all the paperwork and
yeah I got a loan now too now uh
18 2018. that's a crazy story how are
you feeling amongst Source we uh was it
stressful going through all of that it
was stressful it was actually very
stress stressful
but the way I did it I didn't just you
know
just
um call them and say yeah I'm gonna go I
actually win so his office yeah face to
face and told him what I want yeah
um but yeah look back now like
and that was so like there was Brave
like so brave of me to go straight to
the um
the CEO and tell them that I want to go
to Tasman yeah right yeah but the people
yeah most people there then
they didn't like it um
they didn't like me going to Tasman um
um
yeah yeah and when they're telling you
that
um you know you're not ready all this
stuff
um
how did that make you feel did it give
you a sort of a chip on your shoulder to
show them that I am ready or that you
sort of lose a bit of Confidence from it
not
I was sad or like I was I was I was sad
I've um started thinking like man am I
good enough yeah
um
because he said to me like you need to
be 110
you need to run like under five you know
Bronco
and all that kind of stuff like I want
my loose forward to be fast break strong
yeah yeah all that kind of stuff you
know and
that
you know that you know that I still
think about it now like yeah
um they've made they made me you know
work work even harder like you know for
what he's when he said I'm not good
enough and I was like okay I want to
show you yeah
um at this time why I said you probably
know that every time we play Auckland
yeah
[Music]
yeah didn't like what they said to me
yeah because I grew up there thinking
yeah I'm an Auckland boy
I'm gonna play the blue for the blues I
want to play for Oakland that's all like
you know I wanted to do before yeah
for them to saying that wasn't good
enough not Auckland you know yeah but
like the person they said I wasn't good
enough I wasn't ready that's why like
Auckland Auckland the police of us it
was overplayed against my favorite game
of the year yeah
[Laughter]
Oh They'll be regretting that yeah
so then you move down to Nelson how did
you how'd you feel down there what do
you think man
I remember my first day there
everyone just made me
it was humble very humble um
travel um drove from Nelson to blending
my first
um Wilder Squad training and then drove
back
hour and a half two hours yeah
um it was very humble by like the people
people
um in Nelson or like people you know it
worked for Tasman and everyone who came
up to me to say hi they just made me
um they made me feel welcome my first
day even Shane you know
um Leon everyone was you know Italian
just made me um feel welcome my my first
day
and I was like man
I'm not leaving I'm staying here
and you're a man of your word you're
still there still there
and you obviously won a few competitions
um with Tasman as well and I could
imagine hearing you speak now that one
against Auckland
um up there a few years ago would be
right up there for you okay yeah it'll
be right I reckon it'll be
I'll say probably yeah
favorite game favorite game ever ever
well yeah the first game ever
I'll say
because they um North Harbor beat us
you know wow yeah welcome beat us all
the big all the big city beat us the
year
um
and somehow we managed to you know made
made into their final and to play them
um
at Eden Park
the two coaches today I wasn't good
enough they were called in their finals
sure
um
yeah
even now like a man a stove you know I
can see it still thinking about it their
final yeah um
man it was actually like
yeah
it was like a
like a relief like all of you know
everything was in my shoulder to you
know beat them at Eden Park those two
coaches are still coaching that team you
know
yeah good memories and or even back to
last year's Super Rugby final against
the blues it must be another special one
for you it was pretty special I wasn't
wasn't playing I didn't play but it was
pretty you know special yeah to play
them you know in park in front of their
people
and then I think that's the first time
or second time we play a final week and
everyone yeah no it was pretty special
so how did you get your Crusade
opportunity was it just from playing
well in Tasman someone like a goodie or
someone just knew how could you earn
tried to get you down yeah um so
Kayla Nelson not alone 2018
I was talking to the police at the time
um in 2018
they were saying yeah well um okay no
sign you and stuff and then
I got injured in 2018. it in Nelson um
it was the it happened in the last
um last game of the storm week
on a Sunday I got injured did my rough
and I did my achilles in the warm-up um
went back home so I went back to
Auckland I was still signing off walking
for the next two years so I went back to
Auckland
never heard from uh they never heard
from them anything true
um so I went back home did all my rehab
but I remember when I left
um Nelson Leon said to me we'll bring
you back
and I said oh okay yeah maybe it was
just a weird like you know so I went
home and then did all my rehab and stuff
and then
um I think it was my second two games
back I thought from my achilles I play
two Club rugby um games in Auckland
could you bring me
um You Rang me said I'll walk into heavy
back and we'll sign you
you're signing for three years oh sure
yeah Jason yeah I was only for four
years
and I was like yeah I'm doing that I'm
100 go to Nelson
I did exactly the same went up to the um
the office upstairs
said to them
um I've decided to you know I'm gonna go
play for Tasman um
straight away
no hippie you know but at least I went
up and yeah I told him I'm going to tell
him so they end up releasing me from my
contract
so yeah move to Nelson then in yeah 2019
had a good season right from the start
um first round
play well and then I think it was after
the fourth or fifth round
hit the blues
um the blues oh yeah it was Leon
um call me in and say that I walk in um
came to uh sign you but
he couldn't do anything he can't really
do anything because he was I think he
was in Fiji oh yeah and I was like yeah
um they put it off on the table the
first one to put it off on the table and
then
but I wanted to come here sure why do
you want to come here what was that um
you know it's everyone yeah yeah
everyone everyone wanted to be in the
Crusaders right now yeah
um they have won just won the final
again
and most of the guys in Tasman were like
in the team and Tasman not all Crusaders
and
like who like you know the boys like
Dave and them were saying like man
everything's the same um
you know Maps
um like they set up all the same
um the Crusader you'll you know you'll
enjoy and you're feeling perfect
they they talked to me about coming to
the Crusader even before razor called me
not sure
then yeah right
um
yeah razor sent me a text and said um uh
you came to talk
showed away I was like man
I think I'm getting a contract from the
Crusaders
yeah he end up call me and he said um
yeah I still remember he said it or he
came to um come to the Crusader next
year I was like
um yeah a couple days after they put a
um put it off on the table wow yeah
crazy but the hardest part is to have to
you know
um let the two at the two other team
they have signed with Crusaders but my
yeah age my age and just
um send me through what to say to them
yeah so I'll just rang you know ring
them and told them yeah
um I'm gonna sign here um
cool and what's that four four titles
later or five titles later for you four
four title man what one's your favorite
one
I'll say I'll say my first one oh yeah
uh against the Highlanders I was I came
off the pinch um that year but I reckon
last week was probably the
yeah yeah the highlight of my you know
my time here the Crusaders yeah starting
in the foreign
good memories good memories and
obviously you spoke about your dream of
becoming an all black and now
um you're obviously made yourself
available for Tony pay for Tonga now how
hard was that and what made you
um
make that decision
it wasn't
the the tolling coach um he's been
talking to me for
you know she won the Golden Boot
um for like a couple years like oh maybe
my first year into rugby yeah 2020.
it's been like you know
asking me if I'm gonna play for Tom and
uh
I just said to him like I was I didn't
cut him off I just said to him um
my my dream is you know becoming all
black um
um and just focus on playing good for
crusaders and not until last last year
started last year um because I was
coming back from injuries last year
and then he asked me again he said uh
well um we've got a tour in July uh you
came to um come play and I was like let
me let me talk to my family and talk to
my agent about it
and I thought about it I thought about
playing for tomorrow for like a couple
weeks
and then I was like man
first of all like Duluth Ford that all
blacks have of the oh yeah yeah oh yeah
or you know best best best in New
Zealand
um
right I was like man where can I fit in
that team you know I'm not tall
I'm not big
um maybe a seven maybe I can you know
fight for the startup for that seven
Sport and all birth
and I was happy and if I stay in New
Zealand
for another couple years and wait for
those guys to leave that's waste of time
knowing that the World Cup was you know
this year so I came back from injuries
um
pay you I think I played two game
and I said to um the coach I'm I'm gonna
come I'm gonna come and play this year
um yeah
that's man that's that's how I shouldn't
you know changed my all black dream to
pay for tour
um I just didn't want to waste time
waiting um
why not like go play for my country
um this year and you know hopefully
World Cup yeah
um yeah is it take the pressure off you
once you'd made that call because
obviously you've got this expectation in
the back of your head to be an all that
to follow the Golden Boot um all the
guys I've won and be counting that all
back so you obviously had this
expectation and for sure on yourself to
do it when you'd finally decided you're
going to plant National for Tonga did
sort of
did that sort of take some pressure off
yeah yeah 100
um
yeah kind of you know kind of you know
take all the pressure on my shoulder
like to be an awful
um or you know
but even yeah even now like family and
stuff like
and they're still like you know saying
that I should have just wait and I was
like
um now I play for my country now I'm
happy you know
um I have one [__] I have one Super
Rugby Title One miter 10 title
now it's probably time for me to you
know get back get back get back to my
[__] you know go play for time
hopefully help you know help them yeah
surely and your plans going forward
you um where are you next year
um
I don't mind saying it but um
I signed off from one for two years yeah
um and then silent Tasman for another
two years sorry about to all start all
the my new contracts start next year
um
looking forward to that obviously you're
going to be a big part of the site up
there be a leader and influential player
yeah I can't wait
um
that's not gonna be the same it's not
going to be the same as here uh it's
gonna be tough
um but
I'm most looking forward to it like you
know
take my what I've learned here and my
experience hit here and take it up there
to Auckland and
help help you know help them the monitor
team you know
help them
get to you know where they want to you
know go next couple years so yeah it's a
great signing form from Moana to pick
someone like you up like you say you'll
give so much to that group
um you're going to be a dominant Force
yeah chop tackling everyone
hey it's the last thing they need is
more physicality
yeah you're gonna bring it
yeah I can't wait you know um
us Islanders we love you know love being
physical up there but we've got to be
smart you know how we do it
it's an 80 minute game it's not 40.
that's why I'm looking forward to help
help them that way yeah
and I've learned yeah I've learned so
much here like you know you've got to
you can't be
you can't be physical physically it
can't be tough for 40 money you've got
to do it for 80 minutes yeah plenty of
questions came in for you um especially
from some of your teammates over the
years
um a lot of them are around your
nicknames actually you've got a lot of
nicknames though like
um heaps of different ones so I'll get
you to explain a few of them
um first time was John hurricane
uh
the yeah the guy that actually gave me
that nickname was Shannon for sure oh
was it
um it was over I think yeah we're
playing Northland up north
um we went out for coffee
off the team that morning and um
we're all sitting on the table
um
I can't remember who was I think it was
um corny oh yeah yeah oh
the the girl came and asked for our
order and say oh like what do you want I
said
flat white and I wrote John
and then my coffee came and um going was
like what's drawn and I said to her mom
um John and Tonga is like shiny and he's
like oh yeah but what's um
what's heavily
but Shannon was sitting right next to me
on the table before I even like you know
explain how Billy in English the
hurricanes
and I was like oh my gosh and that's how
yeah that's how my The Joint hurricanes
um came about and yeah ever since the um
they call me John it's funny but I don't
even I don't I don't care yeah
I find it funny okay what about the
nickname
Bob
I don't know if I want to say this but
um it bothers Chinese
um husband yeah
because I spent a lot of time and uh
Jenny's offers um yeah my NASA was the
one to start calling me um
okay what about this one um excuse my
Tongan but
ulu
who was that
[Music]
what is that um
because I was growing up I said a little
kid back home um
when I was growing up in Tonga and my
Village
um
but when I was a young man I was like I
was skinny my but my head was massive
how are you
um so before you always big hit and then
um yeah when I was a little like
they had even now like probably
everything's kind of even now but when I
was growing up but
yeah yeah the body was like small for
the head was like um
and that's how like yeah people even
like now
people back home like I'm playing you
know rugby now
um playing on TV but people every time I
go back home people still call me that
day
you still call me the name oh that's
funny okay next one uh tell us the story
of when you celebrated on the final
whistle whistle when Grandma lost to
Ken's what happened here it was my last
year's cool um replacing Ken's at home
and I thought we won so when the rest
Farm Brother last week so I jump up and
like you know
celebrating they don't know I thought we
won man yeah
I found out after the game we didn't win
the game embarrassing
it was against uh who was Captain the 14
kids it was those bubbly oh sure okay
it was on TV tonight oh no you didn't
kick the ball out or anything
oh that's funny
okay next one um sioni is not the
biggest six but he is a beast at
tackling advice for smaller players
um
like I said before like you know
that was my point of this one
um not at all tall tallest or I'm not
vague you know for a loose forward but
there was Defensive was my
something that I bribed myself
um is it Loose forward and
something that yeah
I wanted to you know
um
make people you know remember people
remember me as you know this little guy
little looks forward that you know can't
tackle people you know can you what what
is your mindset going into the tackle
um
I might yeah my mindset is just like you
know smashing people
um
doesn't matter if you're big you know
it's more I always wanted to
whoever I tackle like make them feel
like you know feel my shoulder
uh and then the next yeah the next time
they'll run it they won't run it again
um
that is my mindset you know yeah every
time I take with people I want to make
sure they don't want to run at me again
mate well you even did that to me I
think it was the first time I'd had the
pads for someone you asked me if I could
run the pad at you for a couple of times
and I reckon I got three whiplashes in a
rally I've never held a pair for someone
again so mate I've felt that Force even
through a pad but it is cool um you
might say it was your size something
that people always said would hold you
back or yeah
yeah my size my height is something that
people always like say I sometimes like
I don't sometimes I like read it on
social media
but the yeah the thing is that they all
say like I'm the I'm not tall I'm not
booed by like I'm they will say that I'm
tough you know kind of like I like it
when yeah you know yeah yeah
um
toughest ever okay next one hardest
player to tackle
I reckon Mamba is that yeah slippery
yeah actually man he's been on fire this
year yeah it's been yeah it's been good
this year
man Arkansas the hottest player I like
to tackle
there's a couple times like I've throw
everything and it still managed to like
get off my shoulder
even the game this year when I I heard
him and then somehow he like you know
got his way his legs away in his
um I've ran the like yeah
we played
um play the Bruce this year yeah yeah
he's hard to take it yeah okay and next
one when is he coming back to Tonga
[Music]
World Cup
but then um yeah I'll go back again on
on the um for customers I'm taking my
partner
my you know my son yeah and her parents
mum and dad to you know take them home
and get yeah get my you know both family
to meet each other it's gonna be a cool
way and yeah all right how good and
another part of that question was and
how was your hit how how big is your
head
oh man so that's everyone's yeah
everyone back home no
Naomi is a you know a big head
um
and I've got a photo of me when I was a
little man oh you gotta send it yeah hey
look back down like my head was like
that big and then my body's like tiny
um I've yeah their nickname kind of you
know
run away for ages not until like my
people from back home moved to New
Zealand in brought it up again they
brought it up again and I was like man
not again I don't want this name again
so when's your Sanjay
um the 13th of July oh anytime
um from now on oh wow hopefully not this
week now how big has his head look in
the scans is he good yeah
my father's like man I can't I don't
want to push like you know push out
there like the size of a hood
hopefully it's not big though hopefully
he's got mums here yeah hopefully he's
got mum's head and Dad's toughness
okay what's the best piece of advice
Razer has given you
best advice that guy hasn't given me
um
he always tell he always said to me like
God don't be the best vision of myself
um Ray always he always gave me
confidence every time
and um yeah it always said to me up
before the game's like be the best
tackler out there
um I reckon yeah
even given to me is like be the best
version of myself out there be the best
tech that's an easy for you right you
know you can nail that one yeah let's go
I like that okay
um next one if you combine yellow and
red what color do you get
[Laughter]
I have no idea
oh another one of your tazzy mates
biggest cheat in Monopoly Deal you're
gonna regret that brass and quote marks
um yeah because I used to live oh I used
to stay with Nora Rush
a Monopoly Deal um
like you know take the rubber spin out
to the road haha
you know clean the house like that kind
of stuff yeah and
man I'm not I don't I do cheat if I
reckon noise the biggest cheat um in
that game
um yeah but I always say to them like
don't you're gonna regret this because
Monopoly Deal like you know yeah the
deal breaker deal breaker though you
know you have the payment and I always
like say You're Gonna regret this
oh okay next one uh what's his advice
for buying a white Ute Finance or cash
don't do Finance
what happened there oh
um
I think it was 20 20 um
I went into I went and saw this car
dealership um same albums and
the guy was like that guy was like um I
said to the guy I'll buy the um by the U
like in cash and he's like nah
you know we got um we've got someone's
want to go and finance we will get more
money off um that person than you buying
in cash yeah then I didn't know that the
same day Jenny had um had he talked to
the like you know some of the guys about
like you know finances yeah yeah and
Jenny told them the story
so yeah don't yeah don't buy a guy on
finance so what happened did you just
have to pay way extra nah and I didn't
buy the uh my uniform like um car
company I went into the Florida oh yeah
I don't have the Ute now
um my partner told me to get rid of it
and get a family car
are you ready for kids yeah okay
um what else we got
what was his go-to meal at the hostel
I
I didn't really have any you didn't eat
by the sounds that you would no I didn't
eat I did eat
but I love every food like
came home came from Tonga like
you know yeah they the food I had at
hostels like the best
um and plus I was on here I was in in
the hostel for one year yeah by those
guys they've been there from a year like
year nine I hated true they didn't like
the food there I'm grateful yeah yeah I
was grateful man yeah I was yeah I love
all the foodie hostile to be honest
what's your favorite food that you'd eat
what's your
okay that's the breakfast oh yeah
because yeah in the morning
um after you had breakfast you have to
make lunch oh yeah and I end up you know
making sandwich with the scrambled eggs
and take it to school I was pretty much
eat breakfast
double breakfast yeah it's right on okay
tell us about your
um
up to three tattoo on his arm though
what's that word potato have you got on
you I've got um I've got my my school um
School local oh logo yeah yeah on my
arms so
I had it I got it when I was
14 15 yeah
and go away that's yeah it's it's like
it's normal back home yeah because
people are so proud of their schools
yeah
if I end up going my school have you got
the Marco as well yeah I've got the
money yeah I got tattoos too wow
crusader
[Laughter]
okay two more questions uh we'll
what was the hardest thing about the
move from Tonga to New Zealand
the hardest um
living leave everything behind like
family and
um we're able to contact keep in touch
with them yeah I'll still you know talk
to them on the phone yeah back then um
then didn't have Facebook yeah I had a
phone but one of those yeah the old
phone um
yeah
yeah it was it was tough yeah I have to
leave family back home and move into a
country that
the um language is not my first language
yeah um had to learn everything yeah oh
yeah
my regrets look at you now
okay best piece of advice you have for a
water LED listener
might be the best advice for
people out there like myself
um
don't be scared to tell your story
whenever stopped playing rugby I hate
um interview I hate media and stuff but
I've learned since I've moved into the
Casada too
and enjoy
um you know be in front of the camera
and
doesn't matter English is not my first
language you know
um but like don't be afraid to them
you know tell your story and hopefully
you will inspire like
um
right it's super super cool advice it's
obviously so grateful for you to come on
here and share your story incredible
story and I do think so many especially
young Tongans or Islanders will get a
lot of um got a lot of good stuff out of
that that might Inspire them to make the
move and chase their dreams like you did
as a young kid with a big head growing
up
no I think after the um this talk that
that name will come back again and I
don't want to hear that again
no one will say it to your face though
you're too scared
The tongas are all the tongas and the
people that like knew me from back home
still call me this name I don't care
like I don't mind it like you know oh
man you've always had good bantera
um yeah a good good person to have a
joke with but it's been awesome getting
to know over the last few years well
with tezzy and the Crusaders and I've
got so much respect for you and I love
what you do on the field in off it so
I'm awesome having you on and sitting
down and having a conversation mate
thank you thank you Jimmy mate you're a
lad
[Music]
absolute